right so there's your heading now before
we put any
pen to paper um i sort of mentioned this
last last couple of lessons but let me
say it again okay
um some of you have already met or heard
about or read
about integration and integrals okay now
i just want to do a quick survey
hands up who has even if you have no
understanding of what it is hands up if
you've heard of those terms
before okay all right now keep your hand
up if you actually know something about
them like how to get one
um what they refer to that kind of thing
hand straight up so i can see
that's okay all right thank you hands
down uh now i
assume a lot of you will have okay i
think at this point of the course i had
as well
now let me try and explain why i'm not
going to talk about integration at
all until next time apart from the whole
fact that you know
board of studies says i thought not to
okay because you guys are still
privileged
primitives um and integrals
okay um a lot of people
at least the people who had their hands
up just now who know a bit about these
might feel like these are really similar
to each other okay which is kind of
right
um you might think they're the same okay
you might have even been taught
they're the same thing okay now here's
the thing
um if you feel like they're the same
thing
this is a failure of the education you
have received or the teacher who taught
you that
that they're the same okay because in
fact it's one of the biggest
mysteries in maths right that these two
things actually have anything to do with
each other
okay um so sort of if you ever
you know sat down in the class or you
read something or you watched something
and they taught you okay there's this
thing and there's this thing and they're
much the same
it's a little bit like um you know in a
in a movie
where there's like um you know there's a
good guy and a bad guy but the bad guy
you only find out he's the bad guy at
like very very close to the end right
it's kind of like a big reveal and
everyone's
like what no are you serious you know
it's kind of like sorry i'm gonna spoil
something it's kind of like snape
right so spoilers spoilers you know
so snake well tough okay it's too many
years in advance
so snape's a good guy right but the
whole way through the series everyone's
like it's the opposite
oh really you know and when when you
finally get
the reveal right and everything clicks
you're like really that's who he is
that's his identity
grab a sheet okay and then you have to
go back and re-watch everything you're
like oh my mind's you know exploding
okay
now imagine if in the very first book
okay the very first movie whichever you
watched okay
they're like oh yeah by the way he's a
good guy actually he's like the whole
story like turns on him maybe maybe
someone did this to you um it kind of
like the story is still okay but it
spoils much of the drama
and the what makes it interesting right
so there's a big mathematical journey
that
we have to go on to try and show the
connection between these two
okay so i'm gonna deal with this
and we'll deal with these i'll introduce
them properly
next term if you feel like these are the
same i need you to try and
um unlearn some of that okay um so that
we can give this topic it's proper
introduction okay does that make sense
all right so now that i've told you i'm
not going to talk about this let me pull
it off
okay now primitives what does it mean
uh primitive is well when you say we're
primitive in english what does it
usually conjure up images of people
i actually would think usually justin
but anyway um yeah neanderthals
you know crap current magnum men that
kind of thing so primitive tends to mean
old
right it's like it's like where things
came from okay
so we're using it as kind of an opposite
to the word derivative
okay primitive derivative derivatives
when
you you take something you don't derive
it you differentiate it right
it undergoes sub process and then this
is what you end up with okay
so primitive is like answering the
question well okay
where did the derivative come from right
does that make sense
so differentiating so you have a
derivative
and you figure out yeah okay so
if you have some kind of function okay
for example
x square okay when you differentiate it
you get the derivative
okay um so that's that's differentiate
that's an example right now
the opposite process mark this okay
because it's the opposite of
differentiation
it's proper name is anti-differentiation
you're trying to undo
okay now it's not just
it's not just a um what's what i'm
looking for
it's not just a semantic theme okay i'm
calling it anti-differentiation
and not the i word for a very specific
reason okay so stay with me
now watch this okay if i were to go back
the other way right and
anti-differentiate
so what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to guess
now what function did i come from where
was i
before and then i differentiated and i
got 2x okay now one plausible answer
is x squared as you can see because you
guys know your rules of differentiation
right
but it's not the only answer right can
someone give me another example of an
answer yeah
x squared plus three times seven times
nine divided by
two points
how about one x squared plus one now you
can see this right you can see why
when you go back the other way it's not
so
concrete right because x squared and x
squared plus one
i could differentiate either of these
and because you've got your uh
because you've got your constant term
over here which just disappears when you
differentiate right
you don't know what it is right x
squared plus 1 could also
end up with the derivative of 2x does
that make sense okay
it's not just x squared plus 1 it could
be x squared minus
you know 5 or x squared plus pi or
x squared minus a whatever okay
so what you're getting now is that a
derivative
is not just one function okay the
derivative
is one function it's just a single thing
right
if you have a primitive it's only got
one derivative okay
but when you go the other way you don't
just get one you've got a whole bunch of
them right that are all related to each
other
okay so we call them a family
okay we call the family because um
they're
related get it right related anyway um
they're not just
you know random other functions okay you
can see they have a clear connection
and the connection is uh these constants
sorry i said it backwards the connection
is the x squared
what's different is the constants okay
so in order to
describe this whole family right just
like you know everyone in
a family has the actually this isn't the
same for some constant people but
generally speaking
everyone in a family has the same
surname right so think of your x squared
it's kind of like your surname right
everyone's got that in common
but all of your first names are
different right so
if i were to try to describe this family
i'd say well the x squared's the
important part
and this part over here your first name
which could be all different right
i'm going to call it that plus c any
constant you like
okay it can be negative positive
integer real transit whatever okay
so x squared plus c is the whole family
of functions that are the primitives
of 2x does that make sense
okay now you can see how g sorry you can
see how algebraically that works because
you know why differentiation all of
these can end up at 2x
okay but i want you to draw up a set of
axes for me
and let's see what that means
geometrically question can c
be an imaginary number not a real number
yeah
so long as it's constant because if you
differentiate
a constant anything yep
they are just quantities just like any
other in that way with regard to
calculus anyway
it stands for constant so draw yourself
opposite axis
yeah okay okay so we'll get to a few a
few different examples charlie
i just want to look at all of these
okay wow that's a really wonky line but
you guys can um you guys can do better
once on your paper
what i want you to do is let's let's
draw a few of these together
let's draw a few together okay so x
squared
is going to pass through the origin okay
but
this family right it's a whole bunch of
um
functions which look very very similar
okay now what's the difference
geometrically between all of these how
would you word it
yeah good there's a there's a vertical
shift is the way
we would say it okay or they moved up
and down
so if i've got something like this say
right let's let's call that two right
this would be
um x squared plus two
this would be x squared uh let's put one
you know beneath the axis something like
this
that looks like it's another unit so
maybe that's minus three
so x squared minus three okay
now have a look at all of these
right what does it mean that these are
all
equally primitives of this function
okay it means if you pick a point any
point
let's say i don't know x equals one
okay and if you cut through all of the
different
uh graphs that we've just drawn like um
i need another color
what does it mean right well you guys
know that a derivative
geometrically it means what what does it
tell us
gradium good so if you've got these
three points of intersection right this
one
this one this one okay seeing as all
these primitives have the same
derivative right what that tells you is
the gradients at all of those points
should be equal does that make sense
okay so take it one step further
if i were to draw the tangents at all of
these points
that would be parallel right
okay all parallel does that make sense
okay
as we go through um previews and later
on we get to stuff
um to do with expression you've always
got to think number one about what stuff
means algebraically
and number two what it means
geometrically okay that's really really
important
you can't just have letters and numbers
you've got to think about the picture
what it looks like visually
letters of numbers